[Applause]
that's dumb don't ignore the shadows
that lurk in the corner of your eye
[Music]
they're watching you
the ancient Greeks called them shades in
Korea the phenomenon is called Gowen
ulam which means to be pressed down by a
ghost
some believe the shadowy creatures are
interdimensional beings who are studying
us for reasons unknown I didn't believe
in any of these myths but the fact that
others had experienced what I had made
it more real to me she's Opie cats 1:00
in the morning what are you doing up
reading what are you doing up don't get
smart with me Missy ten more minutes
fine I was 15 when I started seeing
shadows in my peripheral vision my
parents got divorced and my mom and I
moved from DC to Roanoke Virginia
I had a hard time sleeping in the new
place it was afraid of how quiet it was
I was afraid of the seemingly endless
woods that surrounded my house but
mainly I was afraid that when I laid in
bed at night I wasn't alone I couldn't
see it at first but I could feel its
presence like a low-frequency hum
vibrating just under my skin and then
one night I saw it
Dark Void in the Shiva
I tried to fit up but I couldn't move I
tried to scream but nothing came out
you crawled over me brought its face to
mine and then serves you right go to
better I'm taking the computer don't you
ever knock
come on sweetie go to bed sleep okay
good night
[Music]
yeah
did you leave this on all night I'm not
made of money you know if you're not up
in 30 minutes I'm dragging you out of
bed
[Music]
[Music]